kamera läuft ton läuft
bitteschön
hey leute was klappt herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video ich habe heute mal
wieder ihnen dabei auf jeden fall haben
wir uns gedacht also beziehungsweise ich
habe mir gedacht ich musste das wieder
alles mir ausdenke weil ich habe mir auf
jeden fall snapshot und ich krieg da
auch vieles also ich hab das jetzt
gerade mal auf privat gestellt so also
meine story kann jeder sehen aber so die
snap sie mir geschickt werden also kann
halt jetzt nicht mehr jeder aber als das
noch hatte da habe ich wirklich so viele
cnet bekommen wo ich mir dachte so hell
und das waren halt so zu 95 jahre zu 90%
snaps für mädchen weiß welcher junge
schickt ihr da ins netz
selbstwert ist ja eh so horny plattform
also es gibt auf jeden fall viele die
das so sehen der jahren
und genau deswegen machen wir heute zehn
arten von girls auf snap okay leute ich
fange an mitnutzer nummer eins und zwar
sind dass diese mädchen die schicken den
snap das ding ist also das ist ja
irgendwie neu integriert dass man den
schneller machen kann
und du verstehst nichts madrazo
verblödete scheiße und du kommst dir da
5 sekunden von cnet man versteht es aber
nix 105 sekunden eines lebens
verschwindet okay leute das nächste geld
kommt von caro
es gibt immer diese mädchen die auf cnet
chat video history posten wo einfach nix
passiert die sitzen einfach da sein
x-filme sich dabei wie die posen so
mädchen jahre
ja genau genommen da machen die wie dem
wissen dass musik im hintergrund damit
der akku komplett schwarz weiß filter
für ihr leben
so leute kommen wir zum nächsten girl
oder mädchen ich weiß nicht was sagt man
oder was findet ihr besser wenn man kann
oder wenn man menschen es geht
diese mädchen die einer jeden tag 420
lieben ihr outfit posten ich meinte sehr
schönen abkürzt aber oho dp jsl
okay leute ich bin wieder dran und zwar
ist mir gerade was richtig krass zu 1
gefallen also eigentlich ist es ja einen
gefallen weil mir grad nichts
eingefallen ist aber das stimmt ich hab
so ein paar mädchen bei snapshot die
kenne ich auch und die sind ja auch
manchmal feiern so ab 16 darf man ja
auch mal irgendwo den ein oder anderen
klughammer suchen und bei diesem mädchen
ist halt so wenn die dann halt mal
feiern gehen die kommen die disco
reingehen erst mal aufs klo mit ihren
freundinnen und machen so ein spiegels
hält vieles erst mal so ja kann man ja
mal machen nur das ding ist dann geht es
beim feiern blabla eine stunde später
kommt das nächste spiel helfen andere
leute sind darauf wirklich so dass inter
fünf andere mädchen auf dann kommt eine
stunde später noch ein und du denkst dir
sowie viele freunde hat dieses mädchen
eigentlich eine ohne witz und meistens
sind es noch leute mit denen sie
eigentlich gar nichts zu tun hat kann
ich von da die war voll nett
egal ich mache das jetzt ich krieg auf
manchmal wirklich snaps da singen wir
einfach so zwölfjährigen mädchen
irgendwas vor und war dann von mir
wissen wie ich das finden meist also
kein anderes mädchen wenn ich sage ja
singen wir doch mal was vor mir was die
sagen lügen zu schüchtern aber diese
zwölf anderen disney
das war zwar gar nicht so scheiße aber
halt s maul zwar ganz einfach halt die
schnauze ich bewerte das jetzt nicht
mache ich nicht und zum schluss gibt's
natürlich noch diese mädchen die immer
fotos machen aber absolut okay also
schluss gibt's natürlich doch die
mädchen die immer fotos machen aber ihr
gesicht verdecken
ich denke diese macht
ja ist wie schlecht man illegal
das den blödsinn
hast du wohl auch junge leute das war's
mit dem video wenn es euch gefallen hat
dass auf jeden fall jetzt ein daumen
nach oben da wenn ihr noch mehr mit ihm
sehen wenn ihr noch mehr mit ihr sehen
wollt dann könnt ihr gern noch nach oben
da müssen wir noch mal bei ihr
vorbeischauen
der kanal ist und wenn in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und johannes
willig sorgen star am set des falles
angekündigt
links geht es weiter mit meinem letzten
video könnt ihr auch gerne vorbeischauen
über ihrem hässlichen gesicht und ja wir
sehen uns dann am nächsten dienstag oder
donnerstag wieder oder mit blog fragt
mich nicht keine ahnung haben zwei drei
leute ciao